hello there
season five of fortnite battle royale
has changed what we know about the
storyline
dating back over three years now from
the importance of the zero point to the
secret way it functions
so sit your butt down for 10 minutes
slap code adamarrow in the star to come
down this rabbit hole with me
here are six story secrets hidden in
season
[Music]
the five the first thing we have to talk
about is the merging of realities
from the season five trailer we now know
how agent jonesy uses the zero point
to travel to multiple realities to bring
characters here to the island
we have kratos and john wick here now
life is strange
this game has certainly come a long way
but the real mind blower here started
happening a few seasons back
the bottom left side of the island began
to break away and many people noticed
that the island was becoming a similar
shape to that of the one in chapter one
with the bottom left segment removed
this led us to placing maps on top of
one another to outline this anomaly
but that was only the beginning this
season saw many og
locations return in seemingly random
places
but these are far from random these
spots
are from chapter one by overlaying the
early chapter one
and the current chapter two map on top
of each other we can see exactly the
plan here
where the logjam buildings are two years
ago this
was greasy grove home of the der burger
let that sink in realities are
converging
this isn't a single example either the
original flush factory appeared at the
start of season 5
and once again it's in the same place as
chapter 1.
you want more salty springs in chapter 2
lined up with tilted towers
from chapter 1 and now we have salty
towers
by the zero point are old rusted
versions of the dusty divot containers
and once again by using the maps this is
the same area the meteor crashed
in chapter one and then the one which
threw me over the edge
tomato town returned randomly tomato
tomato tomato to me however you say
tomato it's cool with me
but it's not random look at the chapter
one map it's perfectly placed from the
old island
from all this we know whatever johnsy is
doing is causing a collapse in reality
and all versions of the island are
converging i don't know what this means
for us
but i know a man who does jonesy
a few months back i made a video
predicting what agent johnsy's motives
in fortnite are
and this included a duplication theory
in which every time
jonesy enters the zero point a new
version of himself
is left in the loop a duplicate each
joining the loop at a different time
with their own memories intact but as we
know memories fade in this world
even thor struggled here over the years
we've seen jonesy be one of the first to
drop from the battle bus
we've seen him watching a levitating
house while munching on popcorn without
a care in the world
we've seen him marooned on an island and
we've seen him
eat his best friend i personally think
the banana is jonesy too
but that's a story for another time
right now
i want to talk about bunker jonesy as
he's here in chapter 2.
[Music]
traveling down to camp card it's
possible we can speak to this version of
jonesy
who has so much to share about the zero
point i'll break it down now but you
really should come and talk to him
yourself
first thing he does is confirm our
theory about a loop
saying we are all in one big loop and it
loops you me time space it all loops
i know this isn't massive news because
we thought this for a long time but it
confirms those theories
to let us move past that question the
new question is
why do we loop bunker johnsy lets us
know the other johnsies are here and
they are aware of each other
stating nine out of ten joneses won't
tell us the secret
of the loop and then he hits us with the
law bunker jonesy's original job was to
jump
into the zero point to see what happened
luckily he survived so many things
including the volcano attack and back
then
he even made it to the future this guy
has seen things
but now the info we need he states there
is
a way out of the loop i'm taking this to
mean that eventually
fortnite will become another genre of
gaming battle royale is huge right now
but over time different genres tend to
take over one another
like hero shooters become the thing to
play or mmos are first-person shooters
things change constantly and fortnite
has the foundation
to be all these genres at any point but
that's my opinion and not
fact so let's get back to johnsy his
final advice is to keep searching for
answers
and trust no one so ultimately we are
leaving the question of why we are
looped
and going straight for getting out of
the loop and to a reality we can control
and jonesy is the key to everything
wait wait wait wait can you
hear me hear me hear me
in fact there is somewhere else we can
get answers although we have waited a
long time for their return
the seven
quick recap the seven are seemingly
looped contestants in this game of
battle royale
who are attempting to escape it we know
the original visitor who came on a
meteor
and crashed the rocket and cracked the
dome above us and then his bigger
thicker brother the scientist who
continued his work
we also know of the paradigm who i
always thought was singularity but you
guys keep telling me i'm wrong
so i will back off there and stop
assuming they're the same person
paradigm was spotted during the mech
battle to save the zero point
in the best live event ever in my humble
opinion
in fact let's make that the question
today what was the greatest live event
ever this chapter we've seen little
evidence of the seven
although we have seen a carving on a
tree and many people believe
that midas is in fact one of the seven
due to his ability to control his
memories
and build the device which harnessed the
zero point
and now in season five we have
confirmation the seven are capable of
noticing meddling in the loops
the phone call jon jones takes reflects
this and do not draw the attention of
the seven
jones but johnsy missed the message and
didn't heed the call
which gives us the next story beat the
seven will return
around the map are new symbols many of
us refer to as the order
i thought it was jonesy and these io
troops but lots of you guys in the
comments of the last video said that
these are the symbols of the seven
found under the map in lots of hidden
bunkers although there are some above
ground too
the seven are here the cog representing
time
used like a clock and the elements and
symbols upon it
signal each of the seven all different
people but led by one person
we don't know who the leader is yet
could it have been the visitor maybe
paradigm
or even the scientist or was it another
john c clone
we don't know the answers right now but
we will keep on searching
the seven will return let's go back a
second
and look at the bridge
[Music]
for years we try to understand how the
loop is controlled and adapted
and finally we have the ansys the bridge
the mustard we called donald recently
changed his twitter bio to locate
himself at the bridge those who don't
know
donald is the creative director at epic
games and has a great deal of input on
the story
so when he gives us a clue we jump on it
also
he actually played as the visitor during
the galactus event
which i am certainly taking as a nod to
the seven returning but that's not the
point of this one
let's talk about the bridge there are a
plethora of ways to time travel
or visit multiple dimensions in fiction
doctor who
has a phone box and right now i'm gonna
call it there must be a doctor who
crossover in
season 707 anyway doctor who has a phone
box
thor has the thrust stargate has
as well it has a stargate and fortnite
has a bridge
linking time and space using the zero
point the design looks quite unique with
the purple kevin the cube-like panels
using dark matter to project into the
zero point
to create a destination as an fyi i
spent about eight hours reading about
zero point vacuums to write that one
sentence
it's really interesting stuff though but
i don't recommend it
a cool note is that the doorway above is
the same as the vault in chapter one
i'll explain more about that in an
easter egg video next week you should
totally like and subscribe for more for
knife
content so i decided to look into other
bridges
and guess who else has a bridge the
marvel universe
and the fantastic four reed richards aka
the stretchy dude
made this beast of a machine to enter
alternative dimensions
he did this to see which version of
reality had achieved
peace kinda like when doctor strange
does the head shaky thing in avengers
to check all versions of reality for the
best course of the future
and like we've already said realities
are combining this season
so there's a poetic similarity there in
the fantastic four storyline the mad
celestials attempted to use the bridge
to conquer the universe
and guess who stopped them galactus
i told you he wasn't the bad guy he's
just a really hungry fella
in terms of the law we now know that the
zero point is used to create
reality travel and i think the power
comes from kevin
but i can't prove that yet
i wanted to talk now about a few other
things i noticed but i can't break the
code
i need your help clues in the trailer i
just can't decipher
during the scene in which jonesy talks
to his superior we see the room where
the zero point is contained in their
timeline
above the door is a very purposeful shot
of the room number
d204 i've done my best to analyze the
meaning but i can't find anything
why is this room named this is it an
easter egg or
is it something which binds us to the
story in the same scene we see a picture
of the agency
fall from the wall i decided to line up
this image with the one found in season
two
and they do not match at all either this
is concept art which is highly likely
or this is another version of the island
from another dimension and reality
what we know from the past is that epic
love to foreshadow future in trailers
like the sword at neo tilted or bunker
johnsy
or the flooding of the island the future
may be in front of our eyes we just need
to look harder but let's not forget
about the past either
the past can still give us answers i'm
looking at you the enforcer
this is your season so there we have it
six story secrets hidden in plain sight
in season five
have you noticed anything else that
links to the story maybe an npc
i haven't found yet please use the
comments below to converse and build
ideas and i'll check back regularly
thanks to everyone who used code
adamarrow to pick up the battle pass
this season
i truly appreciate you and i wouldn't be
able to do so many videos about fortnite
right now without you
so thank you kindly i'm adam from
playstation grenade you're awesome i'll
see you next time